he's the business of sports podcast host
former nfl executive and you see him on
the mmqb as well he is andrew brandt
back here on the rich eisen show how you
doing andrew
doing well rich i always say this the
off season in the nfl is much more i
don't know interesting intriguing active
than the season so here we go well i
know this week has been uh a whirlwind
and that's why i guess they call it a
quarterback carousel let's start first
with
the decision that aaron rodgers made and
the contract that um
uh he said what it really wasn't in
front of him but is in front of him and
he says i mean everything's still up in
the air but except for the fact that
he's decided to stay
and you know you and i have been
talking about this subject for two years
now
and and
uh are you surprised at how this has
resolved where jordan love may never see
the field again
and it's rogers um from here all the way
through to whenever he's done
yeah rich a lot done pack i mean he
we did talk about this for two years we
were right or i was right
last year they would come back when
there was a lot of dissension and there
was a lot of angst and drama and he did
come back and then this year i thought
there was time for a change
that they would transition to love after
two-year apprenticeship
for jordan love not a three-year
apprenticeship which aaron rodgers had
17 years ago
but he's back
and
now comes the question of the contract
which i think will help us determine
is if like you said they're moving they
really don't see a future for jordan
love or they do
this could very well be rich just like
aaron and brett a three-year
apprenticeship they're running it back
this year they got adams on a tag
they're going forward with their cap
deficiencies and they'll see what's next
after that
and they move to jordan love next year
but we heard talk as you said about a
four-year contract and all these big
numbers
i am saying this
i do not for one second believe this is
a four year commitment to aaron rodgers
or from
aaron rodgers
and i do believe the packers are not
giving up on jordan love
so what what does that mean yeah
yeah wait hold on a second
all right uh you had me at uh at uh this
hello so you
you okay keep going
keep going andrew yeah
i know because i started this 20
something years ago the packers do not
guarantee
true guarantee more than the first year
of the contract and they have held that
through even aaron rodgers last contract
so this idea of 150 million guaranteed
well maybe but
it's not going to be real guarantee the
real guarantee is going to be some huge
signing bonus this year
which will be prorated for a number of
years to dummy out the cap and for
people who don't know you take the
signing bonus and prorate it on the
existing number of years you get a cap
number way down which they need
they'll have a low salary
now maybe there's guarantees quote
unquote if he's on the team next year
that trigger
another whatever 40 50 million maybe
even more in 2024
but
what i'm pointing out is if there are
future guarantees number one they're
probably
probably only if rogers is on the team
and number two they can move to another
team if he's traded next year
so let's get this out of the way first
the fact that they're making a huge
guarantee to aaron rodgers
doesn't commit him to the team more than
this year
number two
here's where i want to really know about
the business of aaron rodgers
last year when he came back
we heard from everyone nfl network espn
everybody that what he got besides
bringing in randall cobb
was a void an opt-out
after 2022.
i thought maybe they'd give it to him
after 2021 but it was after 2022
that is extremely valuable that's tom
brady leaving new england that's
creating an opportunity for him to be
the most valuable free agent in nfl
history
and have pick a number 10 12 15 teams
bidding on him in a year
my question is did the packers
get that out of the contract
or is it still in the contract
because if they got it out
wow
like wow
and then 50 million a year is a bargain
if they got that out
or maybe everyone was wrong that was
never in the deal but
that is extraordinarily valuable and if
it's still in the contract then it's a
one-year deal right then it's aaron
rodgers having now next year
just like brady had in new england
and we'll see what happens then
so there's there's the start to the
unpacking oh my goodness
unpacking that's like dropping a whole
airport's worth of luggage on top of
this thing so hold on a second
you're saying we're maybe not done with
talking about rogers and the packers
being done
is that what you're saying that that
that this
is just a way to window dress up and
salary cap massage
running it back one more time is that
what you're saying a couple things rich
am i am i am i the only one did you not
hear this in august
that aaron came back
he imports his the conditions were
importing his buddy randall cobb
having some soft language about we'll
reassess after 2021
and
avoid
an opt-out after 2022.
now if i'm aaron rodgers or his lawyers
or his agent or his friends or how in
the world are you going to give that up
that extraordinary valuable contract
property
if that was important you before
and you know what just happened rich he
took two months
to decide to come back to a place he'd
been for 17 years
you think that's the end of that
yeah you think you think that come the
end of 2022
he'll just say yeah i'm good again i
don't know i mean i
i it's hard for me to believe that we're
good for multiple years here and then
the other part is jordan love and people
can say well who cares about jordan love
well i think the packers care about
jordan love
you know i've talked about this with you
before
aaron rodgers fell in our lap we didn't
want to take a quarterback but he was
there
jordan love was aggressively and
affirmatively traded up
for by the team
it's this guy didn't fall in their lap
they went and got him
they want him to play the question is
when
so
i don't know is it going to be three
years like aaron is gonna be four years
is it gonna be never
i would bet against never that's for
sure so andrew brent here on the rich
eisen show
uh
hoskins pop-up uh roger's tweet so roger
sent this tweet out um amidst all of the
hoopla
and reporting that happened
um the other day
and he wrote hey everyone just want to
clear some things up yes i will be
playing with the packers next year
however reports about me signing a
contract are inaccurate as this as are
the supposed terms of the contract i
quote unquote signed
i'm very excited to be back and then
he's got the
you know bicep emoji and then this now
based on your
uh opinion now catches my eye he just
put hashtag year 18
with a heart
yeah so
yeah that's what he basically put just
year 18 i thought to myself okay because
i i'm making this out to think this is
it he's now locked in he's retiring as a
packer he's got this contract as a
packer he finishes he's the tom brady is
the packer i call him he's a tom brady
the team that they're going to commit to
him after turning 37 to multiple years
to see if he can do what tom brady did
they believe in him you're saying that
this is just essentially
um you know completing whatever
was discussed
last year to just run it back this year
is again i i know i'm keep on revisiting
this but well so so when i i guess when
do we see the contract terms new league
year hits next wednesday we'll all see
the proof in this pudding right now what
are you saying it's got to be before
that now here's what the contract is
going to look like from a cap point of
view they have a huge bonus
and loads of salary whatever the minimum
is and saves minimums a million dollars
say he gets pick a number 70 million
dollar bonus
so you can add five years or add four
years to the existing year so you make
it like a five year
whatever it is and you per rate the 70
million over five that's 12 at a million
salary that's 13.
you bring it down from he's at 30
something now so you get 18 million of
cap and they're on their way
but you're pushing out a lot of pain
especially
if he's not there
let's just bring this all back to the
contract this whole discussion
we will see this at some point
does it have the out
where's the guarantee level after 2022
that will guide us on the future
but even taking that aside rich i mean
you followed this as much as anyone do
you really think
whatever went on in aaron's mind for two
months since losing to the 49ers
is not going to be back
at the end of this year whether it's
trade retirement
whatever his thoughts have been
that's hard to believe
um i was gonna follow up andrew to say
what do you think uh jordan loves market
is so your thought is zero that you know
they're not gonna touch him he's he's
gonna stay there unless what
somebody gives a yolo deal to gouda
kunst because there are now teams that
are
trading a two and a three for once
trubisky may hit it the quarterback
market is less than uh
what do you think
here well i'm looking at from the team
point of view number one as i said they
traded up to get them it would have to
if you know a thought of trading them
it'd have to be a first
because
when you trade it up and you trade
multiple picks to get up and get them
why would you give him up for a second
and number two is
he's cheap they've got the most
expensive starting quarterback in the
league
of course you want a cheap backup
and i just think i know the packers and
maybe they've changed but brian guticus
is a ted thompson disciple
first round picks are just precious gold
inventory for them
i don't think they give up on them
i'm doing
this is brockman are you feeling the
same way as me right yeah i'm just kind
of like okay
well listen
i'm seeing it from my from my knowledge
and experience of the packers i don't
see this i mean listen rich what's going
on in the nfl this week is all these
guys that sign huge deals one or two
years ago are going to get cut right we
just saw landon collins and
you know
none of these deals are real you know if
aaron signs a four-year deal do people
really think that's four years i mean
none of these deals
go the length but there's no and i and i
know that but i just would think that
the back-to-back mvps
right the back to the back-to-back mvps
moved the packers in a direction of
essentially saying we we get it aaron
you're
you're not having any diminishing
returns
you are um you know
clearly in shape you're talking about
your your cleansing and all that
business yeah and that you're you we get
it you're you're you're a unicorn you're
not gonna be like big ben or even breeze
diminishing returns when you approach 40
or hit 40.
we're in you know we're in and we're in
to make you uh a packer for life
and you're coming out and i thought
rogers after everything would be like
yeah got it
and you're now saying they're just
running it back for a year
and uh
trust me as somebody in this position
i'm all in and having this rogers back
to the packers conversation all year
long and next off-season too but i
thought we were done with it i'll be
honest with you all right until i see
more about the contract until i hear
that the void that he negotiated
for 2023 to get out and be a free agent
without
it's hard for me to believe different
and you combine that with love
i mean if they go to love next year
it will be the exact same apprenticeship
time
that we had for aaron
three years
so maybe you know
in me predicting they'd go after two
years
i was jumping the gun but they were so
excited to trade up and get jordan love
but you just pointed it out
maybe they didn't expect two years of
mvp play
and they said we can't leave this behind
let's go after it again
but yes
i am not seeing this as a long-term deal
so what does this mean for devonte adams
he just has to play on the tag and and
and run it back with everybody else i'm
sure he wants a long-term deal i'm sure
he's not terror
although i'm sure he's thrilled that he
gets to play with aaron rodgers
he can't be terribly thrilled that he's
going to go out on a football field as
things currently stand right now or is
there
just one year
uh guaranteed despite it being a very
nice number
but um what's the plan there do you
think with adam well that again this is
going to be very telling if they
aggressively negotiate a long-term deal
for for adams
then i think okay maybe maybe rogers can
be around for a while
but if they're content which it just
seems that they've been because
they know the number to get adams done
you know whatever the top you know
whatever deandre hopkins got last year
or whatever they they know the number
and they've put him on a tag to just
hold them
now if they're they're just holding him
on the tag and rogers has this out
then we're then we're in the last dance
that's where we are
but if they sign roger's law if the
rogers doesn't have the out if adams has
a long-term deal that changes my
thinking
all right before i let you go what did
you think of the um
the big trade between denver and seattle
quality compensation you like the
compensation what do you think
about the future of that one of those
where you got it i hate people hate
saying this here in this because you
know you have two ones and two twos
judge them it's going to take five years
i'll say the different angle on this
real quick rich the ownership angle
seattle paul allen died
jody allen not that involved
two alpha males up there with john
schneider and pete carroll
they're running the team and you wonder
if
an owner more involved would have
resisted a little more about trading
russell wilson
and the other ownership angle of course
is the broncos
who will be
the most valuable sale in the history of
the nfl
and what do buyers want they want
certainty at the most important position
they don't want to buy into picks or dru
lock they now they're buying russell
wilson
and oh boy does that help the purchase
price as well so that'll go crazy that
franchise value yeah that's what i was
saying is that the broncos were more
valuable yesterday than they were the
day before you know absolutely yeah how
about that andrew thanks for the time
greatly appreciate your insight as
always let's uh let's chat next week
when all the dust settles i'd love to
chat with you again
rich always a pleasure with all that
food for thought andrew brant
on twitter i follow him you should as
well right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here